here is DeSantis responding to the
corporate media attack on this removal
of the AP course Governor DeSantis does
not want students to learn about slavery
and its aftermath well if you actually
looked at what our standards are not
only is it not prohibited to teach that
it's required to teach that it's
required to teach all of those things
it's required under Florida Statutes to
teach about racial discrimination
they're doing it because they know
there's enough people in corporate media
who will just take that and will run
with that so we've got all these
examples cataloged of basically media
lies to try to do to try to do the hoax
in Florida you know if it's explicit and
pornographic parents have the right to
object and it should be taken off
[Applause]
and then in terms of issues involving
American history it's very clear in
Florida standards that we are required
to teach all aspects of black history
not queer Theory but actual aspects of
black history
all right so look he knew the attacks
were coming he has an incredibly
airtight team that knows how to deal
with these people we showed you the
video what two weeks ago Andrea Mitchell
of NBC News asking Kamala Harris what is
it that Ron DeSantis doesn't want people
knowing about about slavery and black
history what does Governor Ron DeSantis
not know about about black history and
the black experience when he says that
slavery and the aftermath of slavery
should not be taught to Florida school
children these people lie about
everything Ken Burns is lying Don Lemon
is lying Andrea Mitchell is lying Anna
Navarro is lying whoopee is lying they
lie about everything but DeSantis is
just going about the business of the
state and if you really want proof on
all of this they have these hysterical
outbursts about all of these things and
then what happens as time goes by and
people forget things nothing bad happens
because of the things that Ron DeSantis
is doing for example we checked in
Phoenix if you could fire up your
computer right now how many gay people
have been arrested in Florida since
don't say gay how many from the DeSantis
goon squad I got a big fat zero unless
were you just giving me the white
supremacist sign no that was a zero okay
so that's one thing
um and we are as he said we are we do
have to teach black history so that of
course is a lie everything that they say
is a lie and what they are jealous of is
that people are waking up people are
understanding what freedom is people are
moving here they're leaving the crap
fact the crap Factory States
I'm gonna say craptastic or Crap Factory
I combine that into one thing
and it's all good here
[Music]